we're on our way to an ice cream shop
it's closing like at the time we're
about to get there Leila she was like we
should call to make sure that like we
can get in hey I know you guys are
closing soon uh can we come in for ice
cream o I'm so sorry I don't think we
can do it in time I called back
literally immediately afterward hey
how's it going oh my God my wife needs
ice cream or I'm going to be in the dog
house what are the chances one in a
million that you guys can stay up in 5
minutes later so I can get my I was like
I'll be in and out I'll be the fastest
ice cream man you've ever seen okay but
you just can't tell anyone I will take
you to the Grave except for this content
that I'm making right
now